whether therefore you eat or drink or whatsoever
you do do all to the glory of god which means
now this is tough i have to tell you
you are not on this earth for yourself
listen to this quotation from a book i treasure
very highly it's called the desire of ages written
by an author who died in 1915 very powerful
writer here's what she writes page 20 paragraph 2
there is nothing save the selfish heart of man
that lives unto itself no bird that cleaves the
air no animal that moves upon the ground but
ministers to some other life there is no leaf
of the forest or lowly blade of grass but has its
ministry every tree and shrub and leaf pours forth
that element of life without which neither man nor
animal could live a man an animal in turn minister
to the life of tree and shrub and leaf the
flowers breathe fragrance and unfold the beauty
in blessing to the world the sun sheds its light
to gladden a thousand worlds the ocean itself the
source of all our springs and fountains receives
the streams from every land but takes to give the
mists ascending from its bosom fall in showers to
water the earth that it may bring forth and bud
you